the 24 year old Marine who protected a
subway train full of innocent people
from a mentally ill violent criminal a
criminal who was threatening the
passengers and who had the rap sheet to
prove that he was willing to follow
through on those threats that heroic
Marine
will now be charged with second-degree
manslaughter by the New York district
attorney
that Marine should be given a key to the
city that Marine should be given a
ticker tape parade instead the liberal
activists who run the city will attempt
to throw him in prison and they will
probably succeed
lots of liberals and even some squish
conservatives will say that
you know if the evidence proves this
young Marine's innocence well then he's
got nothing to fear
but we already know that he won't get a
fair trial because this is a political
prosecution and the way that we know
that is that the altercation on the
subway occurred 11 days ago and no one
previously arrested him because the
killing was obviously Justified then
liberal activists AOC all The Usual
Suspects they called the mob out against
him
so now he's being prosecuted and he will
be convicted regardless of what the
evidence shows or if he's not convicted
there will be hell to pay because the
mob demands its pound of Flesh it is a
hideous miscarriage of Justice what is
going on
but at least the most self-aware liberal
activists know that for them that is the
point I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
there's a professor
the Community College who has been
placed on leave for the egregious
unforgivable crime of handing out
Jeremy's chocolate bars we will get to
that I think we will be able to speak to
that Professor live a little later on in
the show first though speaking of law
enforcement
yesterday
a liberal journalist at a briefing at
the White House asked the Secretary of
Homeland Security Alejandro mayorcas
what has gone on with those border
patrol agents who were whipping all of
the migrants and how all of this relates
to the new surge of the Southern border
and
credit
the secretary corrected the record and
said that the border patrol agents never
whipped the migrants
sir the southern border is not just
Mexicans it is Haitians it's Africans if
we as we've seen particularly with that
issue with the Haitians being whipped
with the reins or the horses
what is there well let me just correct
you right there because actually the
investigation concluded that the
whipping did not occur
all right I
asked something from the horse range
from a horse I I maybe the the video or
the picture was fixed but what I saw was
totally different I'm sorry um yeah I'm
gonna leave you as uh corrected
this is so good on him for admitting the
truth everyone's now giving a lot of
plaudits to mayorkas and they're all
making fun of this journalist woman I'm
kind of on the journalist woman's side
not because the whipping happened the
whipping obviously didn't happen I never
really thought that it did I I never
went along with the liberal narrative
that tried to demonize the border patrol
agents
but I can see how this woman would have
thought so and you know why this woman
might have thought that the border
patrol agents whipped
the migrants because everybody in the
liberal establishment the media the
government including mayorkas said that
they did look at all these headlines
this isn't even close to all of them
Reuters White House condemns Border
guard use of whip-like cord against
Haitian migrants
NBC sake asked about image of border
patrol agent with apparent whip
obviously horrific oh yes Politico White
House possible use of whips on Haitian
migrants is horrific Biden says border
patrol agents will pay after whipping at
Haitian migrants while charging them on
Horseback wow that one's even more Vivid
that's from Business Insider how about
this one horrified by photos of border
patrol agents allegedly whipping
migrants official demands investigation
that's from the Houston Chronicle Vice
news you remember that Vice news which I
think is going the way of the dodo says
U.S border agents are removing Haitian
migrants using horses and whips when's
Vice going to correct that fake news
headline and then here's my favorite
this is from axios very respectable
middle of the road mainstream axios says
Harris mayorkas
voice horror and footage of border
patrol reportedly whipping at migrants
complete fake news just a complete op
from the activist level to the media to
the White House and so I don't blame
this journalist for asking about it
she perpetrated a lie she perpetuated a
lie but she was also lied too and people
all got whipped up into this frenzy that
was pushed completely divorced from the
facts and so I don't let mayorcas off
the hook I'm glad that he's not lying
anymore now years later
but I don't let him off the hook he was
one of the people who peddled this lie
and it's not just about the migrants and
it's not just about mayorkas in the
White House this is the news
this story right here these ten
headlines about the whips and the
migrants
that's every contentious partisan news
story anything that could give a serious
advantage to Democrats and a
disadvantage to Republicans
that is what is peddled by our media
with no regard whatsoever for
the truth I think people have caught on
to that
quite a lot at this point
but it's it's like the air that you
breathe it's like the water that the
fish swim in it's hard to notice there's
so many news stories that come at you
every day that you just see the headline
and you kind of move on I bet you there
are even many conservatives who think
that border patrol agents whipped
Haitian migrants while charging them on
Horseback completely made up made up by
the people who now say oh what are you
talking about that's no we just lied
about that at the time because we
thought it would help us but now it
won't help us so now we're gonna we're
gonna admit the truth
this is how the system works speaking of
our very embarrassing news media
NBC is horrified
the the fourth estate the Intrepid
journalists they're horrified
at the prospect
that Tucker Carlson will bring his show
to Twitter because if he's on Twitter
well it's going to be hard for people to
tell them what to say
well listen Twitter was already Under
Fire from misinformation disinformation
all out lies anti-Semitism racism before
Elon Musk took over and now it's gotten
kind of crazy right seemingly I'm moored
uh if you will will anybody be able to
police what Carlson says or is this the
point it's just a free-for-all I think
this is the point it is a free fall
that's what Elon Musk wants to provide
this move by Tucker May cement the idea
of Twitter as a right-wing website
it's going to cement the idea if this
man is not given a list of talking
points and told that he can't can't
voice certain opinions that means that
Twitter is a right-wing website
oh no the journalist might not be told
what to say by the political
establishment the horror this is the end
of our Democracy in America
just so transparent I'm so happy about
that journalist in the White House
briefing room I'm so happy about NBC
breaking down just wait until you see
Anderson Cooper's reaction to Trump's
town hall on CNN oh that was beautiful
too they're just exposing themselves for
the regime hacks that they are
being a regime hack being a propagandist
it's a job every state has them
but at the very least now I think we can
do away with the where the journalists
are Under Fire we're out there on the
front lines speaking truth to power no
you're not you are Court jesters and
court propagandists for the ruling
establishment that is all you do and
then whenever an a journalist with any
streak of Independence comes out there
and questions that official narrative
you all pile on to him you do everything
you can to enforce the power whose job
it is to whose job whose job yours is to
defend okay now when we want to talk to
one another how are we going to do it
are we going to do it through the
establishment media probably not we're
probably going to do it on pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles do
you remember the last time you got a
free phone you started out feeling great
and then came the Hefty activation fees
the four line requirements and of course
the binding contract Pure Talk is giving
you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy phone
without the feeling that you've been
duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right Unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT and T-Mobile
here's the thing you will be on
America's Most Dependable 5G network not
just a similar one
the same one how do I know I'm a
customer so make the switch to Pure Talk
the cell phone Wireless company that I'm
proud to stand behind because they are
proud to stand behind our mission at the
daily wire and they offer a fabulous
product they've got a us-based customer
service team which frankly is more than
enough reason I think to make the switch
to help you make the switch in as little
as 10 minutes go to puretalk.com Knowles
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans by Americans
forget NBC
forget that lady in the White House
briefing room the greatest media moment
of the last
six months two years I don't know
CNN's reaction to the CNN Town Hall
featuring Donald Trump his first big TV
appearance since he was president
I I don't
this might be the funniest clip I've
ever seen in my life
many of you have expressed deep anger
and disappointment many of you are upset
that someone who attempted to destroy
our democracy was invited to sit on a
stage in front of a crowd of Republican
voters to answer questions and
predictably continue to spew lie after
lie after lie and I get it it was
disturbing and it was certainly
disturbing to hear that audience young
and old our fellow citizens people who
love their kids and go to church laugh
and applaud his lies and his continued
defamation of a woman who according to a
jury of his peers he's sexually abused
and defamed
as good a job as Caitlin Collins did
trying to fact check him it is
impossible to fact check fully because
he lies so shamelessly you have every
right to be outraged today and angry
never watched this network again but do
you think staying in your Silo and only
listening to people you agree with is
going to make that person go away
we're sorry you can turn off CNN it was
terrible we had
the president
we had the president very popular
president come on he's going to run for
president again half the country likes
him
Anderson Cooper I guess is trying to
make this point in a way he's more
reasonable than most other people in The
Establishment media in that he's saying
look it's important to hear from the
leader of the political opposition we're
not such a totalitarian society yet that
we can all agree to just throw the
leader of the opposition completely in
the gulag I know that we Liberals are
trying to prosecute him I know we're
trying to throw him in prison
I know all the while we decry of
Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping for doing
exactly the same thing but we it's
different when we do it and I know that
we're but we're not there yet
okay we haven't reached the the degree
of political control that Putin and she
have in their respective countries and
so we've got to at least pretend like we
should maybe hear from the political
opposition what makes the clip so funny
is just the seriousness
many of you
or deeply troubled by what you saw last
night
it was the former president saying that
we need a better economy
last night we saw this madness evil man
the four
and he said that we used to have more
Law and Order and we should restore
Justice
can you imagine oh goodness
scares me it's going to keep me up at
night
now speaking of contradicting the
liberal narrative
and speaking of accidentally conveying
some truth actually there's a guy who
just won the Pulitzer Prize and he's a
guy who thinks that he's a chick
and he's won the Pulitzer Prize now uh
for his writing he's a book critic in
New York Magazine
he won the 2023 Pulitzer and he's he's
known as a pro-trans writer so this is
where it gets a little bit controversial
in 2019 this guy his name is Andrew Chu
he now goes by Andrea he published a
book called females in which he said
things that were deeply misogynistic
I almost never use that word but they
were they truly expressed a contempt and
a hatred for women and you sometimes see
this this line of thought and this
inclination among the transgender
movement not all the time but some of
the time and so here's what he said
in his book females he said getting f'd
makes you female because f is what a
female is
he describes himself as a once being
quote a sad pretentious boy Furious
about rape hopelessly addicted to
pornography
he says almost every night for at least
a year before I transitioned I would
wait till my girlfriend had fallen
asleep and slip out of bed for the
bathroom with my phone I was going on
Tumblr to look at something called
porn this is that kind of pornography I
did an interview with the the editor at
Redux and actually the story comes from
Redux this is the hypnotism pornography
that plays a large role in people
transiting themselves but no one really
wants to talk about it so this guy
admits it this guy who just won the
Pulitzer Prize he said yeah this kind of
pornography transmed me I looked at
something called porn I discovered
it by accident one night scrolling
lazily down a pornographic rabbit hole
and he goes on he says pornography is
what it feels like when you think you
have an object but really the object has
you
it is therefore a quintessential
expression of femaleness
porn did make me trans
it's funny Media Matters does all these
hit pieces on me because I've suggested
that this kind of pornography transes
people makes people trans but this very
prominent transgender figure who just
won the Pulitzer Prize for the
perspicacity of his prose this guy is
saying the exact same thing that I'm
suggesting he's saying it more
definitively than I am I just raised the
question he's saying yes porn did
make me trans at the center of
porn oh this is kind of gross
ugh okay the rest of this sentence is
legitimately too obscene to read on this
show I don't recommend that you read it
anyway but it basically he says at the
center of this pornography is this
body part and he he reduces women down
once again simply to the act of being
violated
okay
people are going to attack him a lot of
people on the left are attacking him for
letting the secret out I think he
probably deserves the Pulitzer if if he
doesn't deserve the Pulitzer he's at
least more deserving of the Pulitzer
than other people who have won it or who
have been finalists in recent years I
think of that guy Tony he's he codes who
he won the national book award and he
was a finalist for the Pulitzer that guy
has never said anything interesting in
his entire life all he does is just
parrot
silly Normy liberal platitudes and tells
liberal white people what they want to
hear and he certainly does not deserve
any of these awards at least this guy is
upsetting the norm at least at least
this poor man suffering from
transgenderism who got totally addicted
to this weird kind of pornography and
he's got all these extremely perverse
ideas about what a woman is deeply
misogynistic ideas at least he's saying
something that one upsets the status quo
and makes people think but two I think
reveals
really troubling aspects of modern
leftism of where liberalism leads in
society and of what transgenderism
means what it does what it what it
reduces you to
I I
may even read the guy's book
it's so wrong I mean this is the this is
the silver lining in the storm cloud of
transgenderism is
with a lot of liberal policies it's easy
to keep it out of sight out of mind it's
easy to to ignore and neglect the
absurdity of it all
so even even with something as serious
as abortion with abortion you just don't
see it right abortion is what happens in
that dark corner of town in that scary
looking building but you don't have to
see that you don't need to go over there
abortion it's an act of murder but it
occurs inside a woman's womb most of the
time and so you don't need to think we
can just ignore it it's okay but with
the transgender issue which people could
ignore for a long time because there
were three or four people probably on
Earth who actually Express themselves
this way now it seems to be everywhere
it's in your kid's school it's in your
workplace
it's on your daughter's sports team and
so you can't ignore it anymore and it's
so absurd this guy Andrew Chu is just so
obviously not a woman and the way he
describes women being f'd is what a
woman is
being afted is what a female is he says
getting f'd makes you female that's so
obviously not true it's so hideous it's
so perverse it's so obviously the the
hysterical ranting of someone whose
brain has been melted by pornography
that that you begin to wonder okay what
else is wrong about this movement so I I
hand it to him great great stuff man now
speaking of the transgender Mania
I got a story for you got a story here
it's from just the news
about a professor who was placed on
leave
for giving out chocolate bars
this professor is David Richardson
David Richardson is a 33-year veteran of
the state center Community College
District he has 27 years as a full-time
tenure track history instructor
uh he's he's one teacher of the year
Madeira Chamber of Commerce president's
medal for outstanding faculty at Reedley
College for the Madera campus he has
never once in his entire career had a
bad professional evaluation he's never
had a complaint of any kind
until 2021 right around all of this
crazy pronoun transgender Madness and
now this man who by all accounts all
evidence around is an outstanding
Professor who everybody likes because he
handed out a politically incorrect
chocolate bar I don't even want to go
that far a chocolate bar
that made a little bit of a joke about
how men and women are different because
of that this guy has been placed on
leave we need to protect ourselves not
just in our careers we need to protect
our bodies that's why you got to check
out bulletproof everyone right now I'm
going to bulletproof everyone.com use
promo code Knowles
bulletproof everyone is a premier
American Body Armor manufacturer and
supplier designed and built for everyday
wear their unique armor systems offer 25
more coverage than standard armor while
maintaining flexibility and all-day
wearability bulletproof everyone's ultra
light armor system is so light it's so
thin you might just forget you're
wearing it at all your safety and
discretion is their top concern unless
someone puts their hands on you no one
will have any clue that you are
protected with bulletproof everyone you
are not a walking billboard there are no
visible logos no flashy designs they're
comfortable tailor-made clothing system
goes above and beyond adding additional
security by keeping you Incognito and
under the radar work or Play Bulletproof
everyone has got the perfect armor
system to fit your everyday lifestyle
and everyday budget especially as our
political order gets a little bit crazy
great time to protect yourself right now
they're giving our listeners a free 3A
backpack with the purchase of any 3A
clothing with code Knowles at checkout
kwles go to
bulletproofeveryone.com that is
bulletproof everyone.com promo code
Knowles
I am very pleased to be joined Now by
Professor David Richardson
put on leave for the Hideous crime of
passing out a fun chocolate bar in his
class and making a little joke about the
difference between men and women
Professor thank you for coming on the
show
thank you for having me Michael so
what on Earth possessed the
administrators to put you on leave
uh I I can't even speculate on that I I
don't have a clue
I just know that the suspension came
after
I um I was actually at an open house
event
for the college a week ago last Saturday
and we we had tables showcasing our
various programs
and uh I brought some of my history
memorabilia some stuff from the Civil
War World War II
and uh I I always bring snacks
I always bring chips popcorn drinks
things stand out to people who come
at my own expense by the way never asked
for any money for this and uh I had some
leftover
Jeremy's chocolates
that I I didn't know what I was going to
do with them I like chocolate but I
bought an entire case
a man of excellent taste yes I wasn't
gonna eat an entire case
so I I ate some but I brought the
remainder to the open house and I I
didn't say anything about them I just
had them on the table with all of the
other snacks and they actually ended up
being the most popular item
on the table
um you know every most everyone
seemed to get a real kick out of it
and so
um
you know we had one member of Staff who
uh had had not even noticed um when that
person first came by
and I guess words started to circulate
about what the the rappers actually said
and I even had some people asking for
for pairs
they wanted uh he him and she her
naturally and um
then all of a sudden shows up at my
table
demands to know what what they mean
I I directed her to Jeremy
I said you'll have to contact them
they they they wrote the rapper
and took pictures of the chocolate bars
um
that was that pretty much
so um you so you you've been teaching
for a long time it's not like this is
your first couple of years on the job
here you teach you for a long time
you've got a long track record
students name the labia gotten all sorts
of awards
this one
little gift to people I won't even say
it's just a joke you were just giving
people a chocolate bar right can you can
you imagine now being put on leave for
giving someone a chocolate bar and it
involves a little bit of a joke about
this very novel very silly modern
political fad called transgenderism all
of that
gets you put on leave
on top of the fact by the way that as I
read here in your bio
you are not only not
anti-lgbt or whatever they're going to
call you you are a self-identified
member of the LGB community
yes
I I've been yes I'm in a long-term
relationship 23 years
um I I don't like to lead with that
because I would rather people focus
on my
my skills my abilities my
you know what I do
and I've always said last year
um our schools decided to fly the pride
flag for the first time
and I even wrote a statement to the
Board of Trustees at the time I said
don't celebrate me for what I am
celebrate me for what I've done
and
um didn't make a bit of difference I
think they flew the flags anyway but um
that's that's my philosophy
it's it's such an injustice and I think
I mean it's very admirable for you to
say look I'm not
I'm not defined by my sexual desires
okay I'm how about my career how about
my work how about how about my thoughts
how about all of this but it just goes
to show you the extreme lengths that
this movement will go to
cancel anybody who in any way it's not
like you're leading a pogrom against the
transgender Community or whatever
they're going to accuse you of
you made a little joke about a popular
chocolate bar and gave people a little
bit of candy and with that they can wipe
it out so uh David before I let you go
where does everything stand now I know
this this really all began your problems
with the the
college began a couple of years ago I
think regarding the same sort of an
issue same sort of thing I was accused
of
um quote unquote
mockingly
misgendering a colleague
and by misgendering of course you mean
properly gender
yes I use the correct pronouns that
evidently in a mocking manner
and was given a letter of reprimand and
forced to undergo training retraining of
course education re-education that's
that's what they used to call it now
there's a new politically correct
euphemism for it they call it diversity
training but it's like it's it's the
same old thing uh David I I really hope
that you Prevail here in your fight I
know that the headwinds that you're up
against are very very strong it's a
lesson to everybody out there if you
think that this mob is not going to come
for you if you think well look I'm kind
of protected I'm I'm teaching at this
smaller school I'm all I ever do I make
a little joke about chocolate bar I can
no it's it's a totalizing totalitarian
ideology if you in any way diverge from
it this totalitarian mob will come for
you I think the solution is we've got to
get Jeremy in addition to the razors and
the chocolates just start Jeremy's
University Professor Richardson can have
a tenured spot there we will be praying
for you in the meantime though keep up
the fight really thank you so much David
for for coming on
uh and for all the rest of you
very important for this story you can go
check out Jeremy's chocolates because
Jeremy believes that every free American
should have the right to hand out
chocolate that is why right now
you can get the delicious Jeremy's he
him and she her chocolate bars in a
snack size so pre-order Jeremy's
chocolate right now conveniently
available for Halloween go to Jeremy's
chocolate.com and pre-order today my
favorite comment yesterday is from Henry
Biermann who says if I had a nickel for
every time I heard the walls are closing
in on Donald Trump I would have more
money than Trump that's true but this
time they've got him
this time it's Mueller time it's they've
got him now okay you know what we've got
now my favorite time of the week the
mailbag sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data
take it away with a voicemail back
hey what's up Michael Tony here first
thing I just want to say I love your
show it's my favorite podcast Listen to
I've been listening to it every single
day at work for the past two years just
I just want to say thank you for
everything that you do man uh my
question is
um how do I get over a breakup
this weekend my girlfriend abruptly left
me it was completely unexpected I was
anticipating to marry her and get a home
and
you know all that good stuff but she
abruptly broke up with me
we were at my house and when I left the
room she went to my journal and found
some stuff she didn't like so she left
with no warning told me she went through
my journal and that she was done with me
um but I'm having a very difficult time
getting past it so what's your advice
um for forgetting her and accepting what
happened and moving on thank you
well before you move on
I don't think you can move so quickly
over this question of
the journal
there's two parts to it one
why was she looking in your Journal
that would be a serious violation of
trust if if I were looking at it and my
girlfriend did that to me but I would
also probably have the self-awareness to
say okay did she suspect something and
what is that thing that she suspected
and then
obviously this is information that I
lack but what was in the journal
if you were doing something really
heinous you were you were you murdered
somebody or I don't know you were
cheating on her or I don't know you I
don't know what was in the journal uh if
it's the sort of thing
for which you want to be sorry then you
can apologize and see if she forgives
you if it's a problem that you're
working through that you think you can
work out then you know you might be able
to work that out it might have just been
a fit of shock or revulsion or something
that she saw something in your journal
and broke up with you and so then it's a
little tiff between people dating rather
than a full-on breakup or if again you
have the information here I do not if
this is a real proper breakup
then
I would direct you to some of the advice
though not all of the advice from an
ancient love Treatise by Avid which is
called remedia amoris the cure for love
and he gives lots of practical advice
some of which is somewhat immoral so I
wouldn't follow all of it but some of it
is really basic stuff
burn her portraits you know get get rid
of the pictures of her get rid of the
reminders of her cut it off in your mind
move on start dating other people get
out there very very quickly don't spend
time sitting in your home thinking about
this gal just go out and throw yourself
into that because we're we're
suggestible social creatures and so when
you when you break that habit and that
routine that would have ordered your
mind and your heart toward loving this
gal when you break that up and start
doing other stuff because we're
suggestible and social you you will
quickly get into another sort of routine
but I wouldn't brush over the first part
so quickly
what was in the journal why was she
looking at it is that a deal breaker on
your relationship and potential future
marriage okay next question
hey Mr Knowles big fan of the show
um as somebody who was once a Christian
although I'm still fairly conservative
politically I now identify as an
agnostic atheist but something
interesting that I've noticed from a lot
of young Catholics is how they were once
atheist or agnostics who have turned to
Catholicism uh could you possibly
explain this trend I'm just curious by
it thank you love the show I can't
explain this trend because it happened
to me
atheism especially in our age appeals to
people who fancy themselves intellectual
and it appeals to people who want to
appear to be smart and that stupid like
all those rube Hicks who believe all
those crazy things like the existence of
God you know the thing that
the most intelligent people for all of
human history have believed in
Catholicism appeals in particular to
these sorts of people because
Catholicism has such a rich intellectual
tradition
there are other shades of religion that
are a little more emotivist or a little
more
hokey
that that
young would-be intellectuals will recoil
from but
if you fancy yourself a smart person
and I remember when I was an atheist at
about 13 which is the perfect age for
thinking you're much smarter than you
actually are
uh
if you fancy yourself an intellectual
then what happens when you encounter
Saint Thomas Aquinas if you fancy
yourself an intellectual what happens
when you encounter Saint John Henry
Newman if you fancy yourself an
intellectual what happens when you
encounter Pope Benedict XVI you know
these are people who regardless of
whether you think that you agree with
them on these sorts of questions or not
these are people who are all much more
intelligent than you are and it's not
even close we we can get along in the
world and pretend that we're smarter
than a lot of people that we encounter
but when you encounter genius such as
you would see in a Thomas Aquinas or
John Henry Newman or Benedict or the
like
you can't do that and so you've got to
take these these ideas seriously and so
that's that's one way there there are
other ways and perhaps better ways to
find yourself back in religion but in
the modern age for the modern atheist I
think the intellectual route is very
effective and then I think one of the
draws of Catholicism is the the rich
symbolism of traditional liturgy I'm not
talking about the modern post-vatican ii
guitar churches Kumbaya kind of stuff
I'm talking about the traditional
liturgy the predominated in the West for
almost two thousand eighteen hundred
years say and certainly since the
Council of Trent but but obviously much
much longer than that where everything
is rich in symbolism everything has
meaning it it you just find a sort of
depth there
and
so
I remember a priest friend of mine made
this great point he said shallows are
clear atheism seems so clear to people
oh yeah there's no I don't see God
doesn't walk into the room every morning
and say knock knock I still exist and
walk out he doesn't do that exactly and
so it seems so clear that atheism is
true shallows are clear
profound things deep things sometimes
are a little bit murkier or opaque you
think about math class
did you struggle with trigonometry did
you struggle with Calculus in high
school I did a little bit at least
well if you struggle to understand
basic mathematics don't you think that
theology metaphysics the the fundamental
reality of things might be
I don't know just a little bit
mysterious to you
probably so that's why I think that's
why that rich tradition appeals to
people okay
I think there are other reasons too but
that's that's my primary reason at least
uh to to present to the atheist okay
next question
good morning Mr Knowles this is
noblegamer from the membrane segmentum
with a question for you
my wife and I have tried to be a good
conservative couple we got married young
we have five children uh but my wife
recently has found lots and lots of
health benefits and a lot of clarity
from all the lib things like the plant
Butters and the coconut milks and the
gluten-free bread all of that stuff
where is it okay to draw the line on
should people eat these things
and
if I don't stop it will I become trans
thanks love the show
well it depends I mean if you eat seed
oils yeah you I think your statistical
likelihood of becoming trans is about
120 percent yeah that's true but it's
interesting to me you say your wife is
into all the lib food things and you
name a bunch of foods that are
considered off beat healthy foods but
they're not quite the same as the as the
foods that the crunchy conservatives
consider to be the offbeat healthy foods
the conservatives now they're not
pushing for plant butter and coconut
milk they're pushing for butter ghee
avocado oil no seed oils in particular
no plastics anywhere around your food
that's kind of more the conservative
line so I'm all for it I'm all for the
crunchy conservative stuff my wife
introduced me to this it's going to
bankrupt me if I'm buried in a pauper's
grave it will be because we've ridden
our house of seed oils and Plastics but
to me that is much more persuasive
than the previous conservative idea
which is oh whatever just stuff your
face full of all this mass-produced
stuff there's no problem at all that was
that was persuasive when conservatives
had some control over the political
order but now all these corporations are
super lib they're super woke you're
seeing kind of weird health conditions
uh pop up in recent years and so I think
it's perfectly reasonable to say okay
well what are we consuming
now you don't want this to dominate your
life
you know you don't want to put the cart
before the horse you want all things in
their proper place it's like that old
Chesterton line where where he says the
problem with the modern world is not
that it's too bad it's that it's too
good it's got all these virtues but the
virtues are all out of whack they're all
disconnected from one another and
wandering wildly
so you've got to put that in its proper
place and that's fine just don't don't
do don't be eating plant butter or
whatever that is
maybe regular butter and ghee if you're
going to go down the crazy crunchy diet
rabbit hole do it on the right wing side
not the left wing side
next one
hey Michael my question today is about
one of your favorite things words
why do you think that the term phobic or
phobia has been adopted regarding trans
or homosexuality it doesn't really make
any sense to me to say that you're
transphobed it's not like they're
causing
fear irrational fear that makes you want
to go
activate fight or flight I just don't
think that makes any sense so just want
your thoughts on that love the show
thanks it's very very simple reason
they do this in order to Define
opposition to their views as irrational
this is what they did during the fight
over redefining marriage they said the
only reason to oppose redefining
marriage radically from what it had
always been is an irrational animus
against homosexuals what if it's just a
rational understanding of what marriage
is and what men and women are
to say if you if you don't call Dylan
Mulvaney a beautiful woman she her
you're a phob you're irrational well I
don't what if I just
am rationally perceiving and observing
that that dude is not a chick
they just do it to cut off debate it's
it's very simple and it's it's often
effective but it's just it's it's the
rhetorical equivalent of
I can't hear you okay the rest of the
show continues now we've got a whole lot
I have my trusted iPad we've got fake
headline Friday I need your help to
discern which headline is real which
which headlines are fake you've got to
go to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles right now check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you